oh yeah I'm Walter Venezia cool even a
crap and this is top 5 yeah
and that's enough of that but you didn't
expect to see this today
we're counting down the top 5 worst WWE
finishers on my Twitter at awesome
underscore Walter I've been talking with
you guys quite a bit recently about WWE
so secrets out
I'm a wrestling fan and had been since I
was 13 years old you know it's fake
right yeah
while I don't watch WWE every single
week like I used to I'm still in the
know about what's happening in the
company and with WrestleMania coming up
on April 2nd I thought now was as good
of a time as any to do a couple
wrestling related video the finisher as
a wrestlers move that is supposed to put
away his or her opponent and most of the
time they win their match with there
have been some awesome ones in the long
history of World Wrestling Entertainment
/ the World Wrestling Federation but
there have also been quite a few really
really really bad ones and that's what
we're taking a look at today these are
the top five worst WWE finishers number
five biggies big ending I like Big E as
a member of the new day he's been able
to show off a lot of his
unique personality and it's better than
what he was doing before this I don't
know yes come out biggie picks his
opponent up on his shoulders and just
drops I'm honestly not sure but I'm
guessing it's supposed to hurt their
midsection otherwise it just doesn't
make any sense
thinking he is a big man so I get the
point of a finisher for him and supposed
to show off his strength
but this doesn't really do that he lifts
the guy up on his shoulder yes the
plenty of small guys can and do do that
so it's not really all that impressive
when he drops it's almost like a body
cutter an RKO to the ribs I just don't
get how this hurts the guy he's giving
it to it's just stupid big he should
have a finisher that suits him better
maybe with the inevitable breakup of the
new day biggie will start a new singles
run with a signature move that displays
a more serious attitude at least
something that showcases more of a
strength because the big ending sucks
big time out time will tell where he
ends up but the first thing I hope they
do with impost new day is get rid of
this lame-ass move number four the
Ultimate Warrior's big splash
[Applause]
the ultimate warrior absolutely alleged
he inspired tons of wrestlers from this
generation and he was a closest thing
she put the rocket fuel he was uh he was
the Ultimate Warrior his finisher
however not so legendary to move
beforehand perfect for lifting a dude
totally over his head then dropping him
face-first on the mat although it's been
called kind of dangerous it looked
effective which is the point but then
the warrior would run off the ropes a
couple times and body splashes flow
after the previous move this just came
off anticlimactic for a guy like The
Ultimate Warrior this was a little too
weak considering he's such a powerful
force a lot of the time he would put his
hands down too early and south himself
which made the move look even worse it's
comparable to other finishing moves from
huge stars that haven't aged all that
well while the move itself was pretty
bad the warrior himself was so over with
the fans it really didn't matter people
were into it they'd go crazy for and
back in the 80s smaller moves like that
were definitely more acceptable as match
finishers he was one of the most popular
wrestlers the WWF ever produced and his
untimely passing a few years ago has put
an even stronger or around his legendary
career so in the long run it didn't
matter much that his finisher wasn't the
greatest but yeah it wasn't a good one
[Music]
number three John Cena's STF
and now John Cena
STF submission maneuver ferrets in
trouble that was a great counter by Cena
we've heard it a billion times
and despite what some of us might think
of him Sina is actually a pretty good
wrestler when he needs to be he's proven
that in big matches time and time again
he even pulled off some impressive moves
for his size pretty well once in a while
and really badly other times the Cena
Quran is my favorite but consistently
the FPS has been his worst move while I
realized his main finishers the fu of
sorry the AAA Cena has beaten what seems
like hundreds of wrestlers with this
clunky submission move thus it is a
finisher the STF has been around for a
long time and plenty of wrestlers have
used it in the past but I think Cena has
pretty much taken ownership of it in the
current era he locked his opponents leg
then applies a cross face until the guy
tap it should be easy to make look
painful should be you know it's bad when
Stone Cold Steve Austin calls you out
for how terrible the move looks the STF
is that what's called step over told
face lock is you got a snug it thing up
for me please I'll do my best I think
what's most disappointing about this
move is that we've seen Cena applied
really well in a few occasion however
what stays in my memory is how he
usually applies it which just looks
awful
the pain looks unbearable I'm being a
little harder on John because despite
the overwhelming success of Roman reigns
Cena is still WWE's number-one guy and
has been for around 12 years now so say
that thing in like we've seen you do or
just drop it all together
he doesn't need a submission move anyway
I wanted to congratulate c9 winning his
16th step oh what's that he lost it
already really it almost sounds like
that title reign was pointless number 2
the great colleagues brain shot the
great khali was once the world
heavyweight champion that's the thing
that happened we all know colleague was
only in main events because of his
massive size he was never a very good
wrestler even Shawn Michaels couldn't
pull a good match out of them but some
of his finishers were pretty good the
Punjabi plunge was an effective looking
move for this giant and even his vise
grip looks pretty legit the one that
makes this list is literally just a slow
karate chop to the head much like Big
Show's ko punch it's trying to display
the massive power of a 7-footer implying
a single hard strike and knock out any
opponent while shows punch doesn't make
much sense since they're a dime a dozen
in wrestling at least it looks and
sounds good most of the time
colles brain shop has always looked
awful the only way anyone could make it
look halfway decent is taking a quick
bump right after but even then it's
tough to buy into from what I've heard
kylie is a really nice guy and
well-liked by his former peers in WWE
I'll even admit that at times he was
enjoyable as a babyface that goofy dance
was kind of fun west Phoenix eliminating
him from the Royal Rumble is also a
memorable moment
I wish the great khali all the best on
his future brain shopping endeavors I
wanted to briefly mention a few
finishers that almost made the list
Santino's Cobra bad move but it was so
over that I gave it a pass also it's
just fun to bend your arm in that motion
Scotty two hotties worm it's probably
the most unrealistic move ever but
during the Attitude Era and after this
finisher always brought people to their
feet Hulk Hogan's leg drop like the
Warriors big splash this hasn't aged
well but I bought it and so did millions
of people for decades plus you let a
300-pound guy jump and sit on your face
not as much fun as it sounds
speaking of which and the number one
worst WWE finisher is mojo rollies hyper
drive type is being hype all day every
day is that athletic ability although
hyper drive I'll tell you this right off
the bat I know next to nothing about
mojo Rowley I guess he was in NXT for a
while form the high pros with Zack Ryder
and since Ryder's injury has been
getting a small singles push apparently
he doesn't even use the move anymore but
the fact that he did in the first part
of it he jumps into the air and hits the
guy with his but if you have an
abnormally strong but I don't understand
in fairness Niomi uses this exact same
part of Raleigh's move as their own
finisher called the rear view but
somehow it's more believable than this
Goldust has also used a version of this
move before but not as a finisher the
second part of the hyperdrive is a big
jumping sit down thing at least when
Rikishi sat on you it looks painful
that was a legit move this is weak as
hell anyone matches with it I don't
really know what else to say
Mojo's career is still in its early
stages but if he did dump this thing
that's a
a step in the right direction I'm pretty
comfortable in saying that this is the
worst WWE finisher I've ever seen let's
just hope it never gets worse than this
I want to hear what you guys think what
needs your release favorite WWE finisher
what do you want me to cover next on the
show leave a comment and let me know
make sure you check out awesome comics
from yesterday where we asked this Henry
Cavill Superman suck also if you're
interested in more wrestling talk
subscribe to my personal YouTube channel
awesome underscore Walter and I'll be
posting some wrestling related content
on there soon follow me on Twitter to
take part in more polls about what I may
cover in the future come back next week
when we count down the top 5 best WWE
finishers see you then
[Music]
[Applause]
you